Okay,
we uh we should be live here.
Let me just see what we can do
and I will get us I'll get us set up.
Oops.
annoying.
That's good enough.
I just need Whoops. My
which I just need my stream title to be
set.
Oh, this is fine. We just have to do
this, right?
Oh, okay. Good enough for now.
So,
let's uh let's talk about what's going
on here.
It's a little weird. Honestly,
we still have some results.
This will take a long time.
I think honestly the best thing here.
Here
the best thing.
Okay, so here's the plan. We just need
to update
a bunch of ends
for puffer five.
Okay.
Have Grock on here.
Don't have Grock on here.
Let me go. Let me flip my OBS for a
second while I just stick Gro on here.
probably just four or five is good
enough.
Well, this works and this works.
Put my screen back.
Hello. Welcome Liberte.
I need to change the screen res.
I can actually see what's happening
We're going to start refactoring.
Hello.
Oh,
buffer train.
Nice. So, this works.
We just go through the checklist of Ms.
I'd say
Okay. Well, so let's just get ourselves
a list of what M's are currently ported
and which ones aren't.
And then we'll kind of go through and
we'll
I think we have a major bug to fix. Uh
fin reported.
Got some tools to fix. We have all the
ends to get ported up and cleaned.
So, I think that the the we have like a
lot of M's at this point. We need to
kind of make a list of which of these we
care about. We're going to keep
all the major stuff.
We actually don't have that many on
here, do we? There a bunch more that we
just have not.
Well, this is going to get merged in. Of
course,
web assembly versions. Okay, still lots
to do.
I convert
drone's good for continuous. Actually,
this being nice for continuous is is
very useful, right?
I vaguely saw a thing. Hang on. Let me
see what's this.
I'd have to look up the background on
whether that's well posed.
The pin is doing some pretty cool stuff
on net hack at the moment.
a really good benchmark.
We'll do code review shortly. Convert.
Let me get all the current M's ported up
to 5C.
I should have told it to do this multi
thread but it's fine.
Vert.
I would actually like to know whether we
have snake working as of the time being.
I broke that at some point. I It's
bothers me.
We don't just have that nice.
Um, so a little bit of background. I've
kind of just been controlled on
algorithm stuff for the last few days.
It's still going to be probably a day of
background spinning work until we have
some confirmations. I think that the
most likely thing though is that there
was a bug in Puffer 3 and 4. However,
the bugged version actually works
better. Um,
a lot of the literature that we relied
on for some stuff is unfortunately
wrong. Like top 10 papers. Well, we have
we actually in the last week we've have
we've found like two problems with two
different top 10 papers in the field.
We are somewhat insulated from the
actual issue though because of muon.
Um I think ultimately the puffer
codebase is going to get a little
simpler and we're going to be able to
drop like four hyperparameters.
But unfortunately
we are we might even be able to get a
little bit of more performance by the
way as well. But unfortunately, it kind
of kills off a whole avenue of research
that I thought we had available to us
with off policy. And that's quite bad.
Or not with off policy, but with off
policy correction for
um nearly on policy algos.
Very annoying.
tab.
Why does this break when I hit tab, man?
And like why is this not just a perfect
policy?
Like why does this get broke? Like why
does this happen?
Probably can fix a lot of these now.
Upside down puffer.
Yeah, I think we're going to kind of go
through and just fix a lot of the ends.
Sweep thing fixed.
PR.
Um,
let me see the oneliner.
I'll copy it from your thing.
I don't have a multiGPU machine at the
moment like spun up to test.
But yeah, that's a really good find.
Thank you for that. I don't know how I
did that. I really don't. It must have
just been refactoring, man. I haven't
tested multiGPU since I did the whole 5C
refactor.
at least not well.
But um I assume then if you're doing
this right that you're doing like some
sort of well are you doing multi sweep
or you getting like a fast 8GPU config
cuz in some sense like the number of
steps that you're doing on Net Hack
right now is actually kind of small for
uh an NV of that complex. stocks today
only doing a couple hundred mil steps.
We've also just had a whole bunch of
algo issues lately.
Peeps weren't finding anything. Okay,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
I actually I wonder whether like
breakout taking a thousand experiments
to sweep or whatever was from this as
well. No, cuz I did single GPU sweeps as
well. Breakout's just a really tight
tuning task and there's probably a lot
of seed variance.
Like this is why breakout is no longer a
good task.
two plus weeks and sweep. Yeah, I really
do think that you need to have more
depth sweep stuff, Finn. Like the score
stuff. If you're going to write a blog
post on score or whatever, like go
ahead. Um because you have giga soda,
but like you have giga soda on a metric
that's bad.
You also have giga soda on a metric
that's good. People just don't know that
that's the important metric yet.
Did you get a Medusa screenshot? Like
has it gotten there?
100k episodes.
Probably couldn't 100k episodes.
I mean, that's fine. You can just run
those real quick, right?
Definitely use the multiGPU boxes if you
need them for experiments and stuff.
like don't please don't leave them
running overnight and stuff with like
idle or whatever. Um but like yeah you
want to go to lunch and leave it idle so
you don't have to spend 20 minutes
spinning spinning it back up by all
means like it's we really really want to
make stuff easy for you to do this type
of stuff. Um cuz hopefully this is a
good learning experience but at the same
time like these are this is not like
your typical internship where it's like
oh the projects may be useful to us
maybe not. This is like really really
really useful for us to have um for
internal research you know like net hack
is a really really good benchmark.
I think if we manage if we get fast
enough and not jank enough right like
this could become our best single agent
benchmark end by far.
It's also possible that craft axe ends
up being better if it's unsolved
um after we like fix some stuff up with
it just because it'll be faster.
But possibly not, you know, maybe
Netflix is There.
Oh, okay.
I guess we actually kind of already did
many of them.
We need to start building demos for
everything.
I'm honestly I think I'm just going to
get an 8GPU box after these basic
cleanups. I'm going to grab the latest
version and we're just going to start
automating the process of like getting
current
new uh demos and stuff.
This can definitely be made easy.
We'll get your oneline multiGPU fix.
What am I working on? Cleanups. Mostly
endside cleanups for Puffer 5. Um, and
new baselines for stuff. I think that
mainly,
so there just a few miscellaneous
porting errors that can be cleaned up
automatically here. And then after that,
so once we have all the M's at least
trainable, I'm going to grab an 8GPU
box, put all this onto the HGPU box, and
then we're going to start running
baselines for Everything.
Algo stuff has been a disaster E10
though. I think it's been at least as
much of a disaster for the uh integrity
of the field overall than it has been
for me personally.
Impala just doesn't work. At least from
the experiment so far, it does not work.
Hello. Welcome. Async does work, Finn.
Yep. Async works. So, uh, the thing with
async, right, is it works. It's a small
degradation. You can hyperparameter tune
your way around it, but most of the
things that are intended to address
async and offpaul lag do not work at
all. So, it works as is. Um, our current
thing is pretty robust, but all possible
avenues of improvement are just screwed.
It's not even a straight reproducibility
crisis, though. It's not like it's not
like the experiments written in the
paper don't work. It's like the
conclusion that they draw is wrong
because their baselines were weak every
time.
So, TRPO
uh that guarantee does not actually the
guarantee that you that it gives you is
not actually the practical guarantee
that you care about which is the
multi-step reuse guarantee. It gives you
a singlestep guarantee. So TRPO was
useless even as a theoretical test. Um
like that was never going to be kept of
obviously because it's slow. Uh PO
definitely that does not work at all
like the uh the clip does not work at
all as a trustbound. It works as a
heruristic hack to prevent you from
immediately collapsing due to very bad
samples only. Um VR is a disaster. V
trace basically doesn't work under any
setting. And then the
the choice of live versus frozen value
seems to matter less, though I'm not
fully certain on this one quite yet.
We're seeing on that. Um, also at the
same time,
prioritize replay, our big thing from
Puffer 3, no longer seems to matter.
However, this one I'm less bummed about
because this was not me being incorrect.
This is a um this is a consequence of us
having longer rollout segments now from
the Puffer 4 architecture. So, that
one's totally fine.
But yeah, it's been like a whole mess. A
really whole big mess
atom on local time works as a correction
to atom. That seems fine. Uh if you push
to very high sample reuse, you can see a
difference from it not collapsing
momentum. However, very high sample
reuse will screw you up due to off
policyiness. None of the off policy
correction techniques works. So even
though you're screwed for a different
reason, you're still screwed. And then
the momentum thing is less of a problem
in Muon anyways because of the
orthogonalization.
So it's kind of a wash.
I don't know what they're doing. I would
be very surprised if they're doing the
stuff that we are.
correct metric for off Paul. It's not
about well do you mean metric or the or
the correction right we can very easily
measure off policiness via important
sampling but the problem is no method I
have tried whatsoever actually helps
at least like not more than just doing a
basic PO clip baseline which trivially
uh you can make fail at higher sample
reuse
and you're not getting like a smooth
improvement with higher sample reuse
either. You're mostly getting like fails
slightly less catastrophically at higher
reuse. It's not ideal.
overview the algo change
basically nothing really survives
honestly I can talk about all the
different things I've gone through right
so we found a bug where vrace was not
actually enabled
um so we tried various forms of vrace
with either a frozen value function a
live value function a frozen advantage
estimate with live importance a live adv
advantage estimate with frozen
importance. We tried all the possible
different variations.
And this was not just like randomly
trying variations either. The key
distinction here, right, is uh PO as
it's originally written uses a frozen
advantage estimate and then it runs
several epochs of gradient descent or
whatever. Um whereas impala typically
you only do one update step but you do
it on lagged asynchronous data using a
live value estimate. So given that it's
actually not clear whether you should
use a live or a frozen value estimate
when you combine both of them. And I
thought that there was probably just
going to be some subtlety in there where
like it needs to be live or it needs to
be frozen or part of it needs to be
live. But after a whole bunch of hacking
around the best I can figure is just
vrace itself doesn't really work. um it
doesn't actually provide a useful
offpaul correction in any of the
experiments I've seen across multiple ms
across you know many hundred different
runs of different things.
So it kind of doesn't matter how you
integrate it because it just doesn't
work. Um which is sad. So now we no
longer really need to design around
making stuff work for the off pole
corrections cuz they just generally
don't work sadly.
It does feel very weird to me that vrace
does not work. Um it seems like it
should work but it doesn't
this is also not like obviously wrong to
me.
comes down to like co-optimizing
your like tuning your hypers for your
thing and then not really testing the
baseline nicely. It's also mixed to
begin with. Like look at this.
Okay, so they have this onestep
correction here
and onestep correction is better on two
of the tasks. It's better than V trace
on two tasks already and the other ones
are pretty similar for the most part
already. So like
I don't even know what the error bars
are here. It's kind of just questionable
the amount that we should expect to get
from Vrace anyways.
Um
I also I don't know it we can look at
the lag thing. Where's the lag
distribution?
We might be able to look at some more
ablations in here, but I haven't been
able to find anything. And I've been
doing a lot of work on this the last
several days.
It's very annoying.
tricked off Paul.
You know, that's kind of the big
question. So, I went back through my
work from 3 0 and
the the thing that I came up with is
this like beautiful. It's honestly the
only good piece of theory I've ever
produced
other than um well, I guess the I've
done some good architecture stuff, but
like it's so annoying because look at
this.
It's just buried in this blog post.
This thing right here is an amazing
result.
This is a two-line combination of
important sampling
with generalized advantage estimation
that perfectly generalizes both vrace
and J. It contains both of them
Um, yeah, I assign less than a 10%
probability this works. Like one in 10
this thing works.
This is combining too many different
things that I know for a fact don't
work.
did you reproduce invala in a simple
environment you can get I've seen vrace
give benefit um if you make the baseline
stupid enough the problem is that like
if you try to reproduce Impala the
baseline is so weak that anything works
so it's not meaningful to just oh if you
can reproduce it it'll useful cuz the
baseline sucks.
Eton then that's probably something
specific to robotics with entropy
because like that does not giving you
meaningful exploration in other tasks
like the off policy sampling like to
distill the data like that doesn't work
the diversity thing like that doesn't
work at all I know like there's no I
actually read a paper. I read lots of
papers.
The thing is I just don't like most of
them do not work. That's why I don't
read them. It's not cuz I don't like
know how to read papers. I've been doing
this for a decade.
Even the papers that look really good
and seem like this definitely should
work, they don't half the time.
It's only for continuous actions. Yeah,
but that doesn't make sense to me.
It's more likely the case in my mind
that robotic spaces just really jank.
Their code bases suck and um they have
some really weak baselines that are
difficult to understand why they're weak
because the code bases suck. I've
definitely seen several examples of this
being the case before.
It's hard to be precise with these
things because if you look at the actual
changes in Puffer algorithm versus like
basic vanilla clean, they're pretty
small, but there's a world of difference
in how well Puffer just works out of the
box.
what the problem is. Um, so the problem
I've been having for the last week is
that we were attempting to make some
optim some well what started off as
making some basic optimizer fixes for
high sample reuse went into finding out
a big issue with our off-paul correction
mechanism to basically finding that no
offpaul correction mechanism whatsoever
actually works.
It pretty much seems that it is the case
that PO clip gives you some stability to
outli outlier samples and then having a
better optimizer lets you make uh lets
you run more steps without blowing up.
But you can never just there's nothing
out there that just ma lets you make use
of increasingly off policy data like
effectively or even without collapsing
basketball and took one bill steps on
default config.
SAPG did
again like
the I've worked with a couple of robotic
stacks. They just have so much besoke
bespoke crap in there that you're not
going to just be able to like slot
puffer in. It would be a pretty
substantial amount of work. They've like
the best way I can describe it is
generational trauma of robotic students
encoded into a horrific like nested
onion of code.
They just have like lots of really weird
domain specific hacks and tricks that
are encoded into a big mess and then
they're all correlated in a weird way
and very brittle.
Like the thing is just distilling from
different entropies is so incredibly
like do you understand how incredibly
janky that is?
I mean even doing something as simple as
like conditioning on a target entropy
would make more sense than that.
Oh yeah. Volo, what? Vol, you said
you're working on Something.
obsides more than half. Ooh,
little bit. Yeah, very nice. I mean,
that does tend to happen, Volo. Um,
sometimes you have to go down those
rabbit holes to figure out stuff.
Sometimes you kind of do it to yourself.
It's um it's a tough trade-off to learn.
800k SPS. Way better.
That's usable.
resource recommendations. Oh, yeah.
I uh I have lots of materials on that.
They're all free.
Just go to my articles tab here. I have
some stuff on our latest research
especially 40 this article here and uh
some of the related like 40 articles but
then my general
uh my general RL guide is here this is
still good
context usage
What did I click here?
Oh, it did four. It went to 4.6 by
default. I didn't even notice. That's
cool.
We're going to put this onto an HGPU
box.
The hell?
That's not supposed to do that.
Grab us uh something decent. Selfplay
truly worked well.
We have some good results on Robocode so
far and we have some good results on uh
on our professional work. Um it's not
selfplay is not solved yet though. I
will say it's definitely not not solved.
Hey uh what the heck? Why?
Why do we only have three results?
Why are there only three results for
8x5090s
right now?
Uh hello.
Well,
64 cores.
This looks fine, right?
13.0 Oh,
up to I'm about to just go grab an HGPU
box and basically try
just run through a whole bunch of ends
and see what we've broken with training
and whatnot
and basically just try to ship us a
whole bunch of new baselines.
Oops.
Where's it go?
do I have
I think I need to add my
Oh no, guys.
Steal my public key.
What the heck?
Oh, that's okay.
We have a 5.0. No,
this is
thought we had a 5.0 branch. Dev
fix setup.
Oh yeah, this is fine, right?
Stop dropping my keystrokes.
Good thing.
It's arguably closer.
Um,
but the optimizer is doing a lot of work
for us.
And that might seem like, oh, you just
switched the optimizer. But the thing
is,
if you don't have Muon, there's several
other changes that you need to make to
the algorithm that become much more
necessary.
And um also the stuff like the
prioritized replay that also becomes
more necessary without the architecture
change as well.
So like if you just run if you just like
try to implement PO off the original
paper without our other stuff like you
will not get anywhere near the same
result.
Arguably we also have the async mode in
now for speed.
arc change our own puffer architecture.
We have a post on it. That architecture
is really good.
Like our arch is really really good.
it's a combination of linear recurrence
and hyperconnections or high
hyperconnections highway connections
Take forever.
Oh, puffer clone.
We'll fix that.
with muon is stuff did not work. Yeah.
So is stuff does not seem to work super
well. It is a very nice generalization.
So if you want to do anything based on
is like our implementation is going to
be by far the best. Um that is also my
own theoretical result
that uh that specific
advantage function.
And again like if you don't have the
architecture you're forced to train on
shorter segments. And training on
shorter segments means that you need
prior um prioritize sampling much more.
So they're basically they're just a
whole bunch of very tightly coupled
things in the design of this
RL on a really slow problem. Yeah, RL on
slow problems does not work. That's not
a fun time. Um I generally
I generally am not a big fan of like
train a neural net to replace the sim.
That's never been a line of work I've
had much faith or confidence in.
especially based on what I've seen done
with that in conjunction with RL.
I have seen a lot of progress being made
just by cutting some corners on the sim
and making stuff dramatically faster.
me? Why not? Yeah. So I will probably at
the very le least disable it and um
remove it from the defaults. I'm going
to leave the implementation in there
because again if you want to do anything
based on is like this is essentially the
cleanest best possible version that you
could want from it. Like
I mean you have like dozens of papers on
one line of RL and dozens of papers on
another line of RL. And
I basically have a twoline change to the
advantage function that generalizes all
of them perfectly.
So that's pretty cool.
There's some still some additional
things to ablate, mind you, on the the
whole is thing.
I This is so obnoxious, by the way, that
this does this 120k. Like, you go and
rent a machine.
What about random networks?
Uh, that's separate. We swapped Puffer 5
and Puffer six plans.
I know that totally on pallo
is A2C. In practice, you're offpaul
after a single mini batch.
You're offpaul after literally a single
mini batch. And yes, it matters. Like if
you drop the clip from PO, you
completely crash PF. I've tested this
extensively.
I'll go. It's 5C stuff. Jess, I'm uh I'm
booting up here a 5GPU or no, an 8GPU
box. And the goal is just going to be
crank all the environment baselines out
today,
like to at least know which ones we can
train on and which ones are good PF and
which ones are breaking and stuff.
I figured I could just grab an HGPU box
and have Grock just orchestrate stuff
and that should just be fine.
Is important sampling. Yes.
And I specifically I mean the like the
endstep VRay style important sampling.
Um Grock really isn't Volo like
Grock you can still do very nice
narrowly scoped things and the model is
very fast.
This is not the model doing stuff for
hours. This is experiments running for
hours. Why not use a tiny box? Because
we have two of them and they're both
dead. We've had GPU failures or like
problems on both of them that have like
taken them both down and I'm not going
to be back at that facility for another
couple of months to fix them.
Um, and we've already spent like an
extra6 or $7,000 in compute credits over
the last couple months as a result of
that.
By contrast, I've been running way more
stuff on my um my 5090 single GPU box
and I've had zero issues.
Yeah, it's to the point that I'm going
to have to start factoring the in the uh
compute expenses
more. So
See, this is why you need your own
hardware as well, because like these
[ __ ] will tell you, "Oh, yeah. Yeah,
it's got like a two gig internet
connection." And then I'm here [ __ ]
doing 200 kilobit clones.
Sharting on the wait. Sharting on the
end side.
I think that's typically just actions or
stuff though, not the core.
just use your single G is it yes it's
very important to have multiGPUs
um especially for what I want to be
doing here
I want to start getting us benchmarks on
all the different ends here.
And the easiest way to do that is going
to be
super annoying though. Like what is
this?
feels slow now. Yeah. Yeah, Jess. Um,
oh, also apparently we had a major
multiGPU sweep bug. I don't know if that
affected your stuff, but um I think it
probably crept in in a pretty recent
refactor,
so probably not.
I'm patching it now. Uh, I literally
just broken multiGPU sweep silently, so
only one GPU was actually doing real
work.
99%
on lag four.
So that's basically the original
setting.
Yeah. Okay,
I'm happy with that. We'll run this as
confirmation.
We actually get to remove something from
the uh one of the original PO
implementations as well, which is we get
to remove the advantage norm or at least
replace it with a simpler form.
Dealing with vast is definitely
annoying.
is this Bowen.
No, this is a different Bowen, right?
ML if I don't have access to GPUs.
You need a GPU.
If you don't have a GPU, you can rent
one for like 10 cents an hour, like a
decent one.
Let me use the restroom real quick while
we uh while this finishes setting up.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
I I just genuinely don't understand how
this is stuck.
It's just complete crap.
Something's weird as well because Vast
only had like three machines listed.
Um they've had some outages.
this is frustrating, but this will
ultimately simplify some things. So, I
think it's fine.
Um, particularly if we can do mazes in
2048 without pryo, that means we don't
need pryo at all, which we might even be
able to confirm that real quick. Hang
on.
Okay. No, this has very strong pryo on
it.
So, we'll have to double check that for
sure.
You have got to be kidding me.
Like what
do I just need to get a different box? I
I'm confused.
Like
Why are there a whole bunch now? There
weren't before.
Uh they've also uppriced them massively.
This is fins.
We get rid of this.
Don't mess with fins.
56 core. What the hell?
I hope
if I [ __ ] this up, I'm going to be
really sad.
No, I didn't. Okay, I didn't just leave
Fins by mistake.
Plus Puffer is working.
10% win rate.
That's fun.
Cool.
I like to see Puffer on different
things.
Oh my god, this is immediately way
better. Okay.
It's immediately way better. Let's get
her install.
I don't know why I keep falling for like
those shitty scam machines.
Like presumably they do have GPUs, but
they're so terribly administered they're
basically worthless.
Something's I know that these servers
are typically fine. So
something's weird today.
That's better. At least
if it goes down to 100 something and
stays there, it's GitHub being weird
today. I actually I think it actually is
GitHub being weird today.
I don't know.
Bizarre, man. It's bizarre.
Let's get this.
Why does my browser not work?
is pryo were both zero.
It's not that is um it's not that pryo
doesn't do anything.
It's that it's the feature is subsumed
by longer horizon which now works
because of the 40 architecture.
Like prior was 100% needed to get soda
on our harder tasks in Puffer 3.
It's not just like oh we did a stupid
thing and over complicated it.
Um, uh, V trace was kind of we did a
stupid thing to be fair and over
complicated it, but it's not like we
just uniquely it's us. It's also like
the whole field. I mean, that's a top 10
paper in the field
did a stupid thing and over complicated
it.
So, at that point, I don't really know
what to tell you.
It's GitHub. GitHub's like something
wrong today. I don't know.
Yeah, I do agree. Like it does really
feel like stuff is just going to hell
and breaking randomly.
I mean like crucial infrastructure is
just like
Look, now it gives us 29 megs a second.
Huh?
Right.
Uh, I actually don't think we do.
I looked at Jai.
There's stuff to like. It's too much.
It's too much.
I think he's he's very good, but I
you could make everything just work in
plain simple. Honestly, I I really don't
think the language is problem.
Is that the cautious var variant or is
it different?
I have not tried that.
I need one GPU open.
I'm trying to think what else I want to
do with this.
Oh, that actually is going to interact
badly, I would think, with um
with sample reuse.
So, we see the optimum thing. I was
looking at
this paper here.
This is a nice thing to find. It seems
like Muan is more robust to this though.
So, we just get rid of this sharded
crap, right?
Okay, let's get started with this
finally.
It's kind of funny actually, like we
would have to change a couple things
about our optimizer if our nets got much
bigger, but uh our current design is
fine up to tens or even hundreds of
millions.
Wait, low singledigit versus Muon
cuz low singledigit overall overhead
would be um like additional that would
probably wipe out any gain we'd get from
it.
No, it's not atom plus
orthogonalization.
It's um depending what variant just
nestrov momentum plus orthogonalization.
Muan works very very well though. Like
of all the things all the different
algorithm things that we've tested, Muan
was the one that immediately gave us a
like big big noticeable benefit and has
survived pretty much everything else
we've done
that. And the architecture, our
architecture is also pretty damn big.
uh we'll leave a G we'll leave a GPU
open on this machine for us to play with
because I think there are a few M's like
snake that I want to make sure work and
we might have to change some mobs and
stuff.
This is cool though. We have 99% on
mazes
at um lag four.
So that's with four epochs of lag. We
have 99%
Obviously, we're never actually going to
have four epochs of lag. This is a
stress test.
value trace never really helps at all.
It actually kind of just hurts.
How do you solve reward? What do you
mean reward collapse?
Reward collapse is not a thing. Like
that would be policy collapse and uh
that's typically bad numeric and stuff.
If you're using torch and torches new
are bad, you just go cry because you're
never going to be able to understand
what torch is actually doing well enough
to fix it.
Um, but if you have full control over
your entire numeric stack like we do,
then you figure out what's wrong and you
fix it.
I mean, it's that's not like a specific
problem. It's not like, oh, reward
collapses under PO or something. That is
like specific numerical jank for the
most part.
Um, that's like kind of like saying how
do you solve loss collapse in supervised
ML? It's like, well, you shouldn't be
getting loss collapse and it's typically
like your numeric or your infra or
whatever.
I put smaller learning rate and then it
doesn't collapse. Can also be unstable
hyperparameters.
You also shouldn't be manually tuning
hypers though.
take 30 minutes plus so I can't sweep
properly. Yeah, then you're basically
screwed is the problem. You can't do RL
if like your experiment cycle is too
long. Now actually 30 minutes is not
bad. Um because you just grab an 8GPU
box and that means that you get
uh 50 what you get 50 48 experiments per
GPU per day. So now you can still get
hundreds of experiments per day.
You can actually sweep now if you don't
have any hardware access. You should not
be working on problems that you can't
train uh faster than that.
The simulator is slow. Yeah, that's
called being screwed.
30 minutes per experiment is still
sweepable with a little bit of hardware
though.
Is it 10x less steps?
Um, I mean it can be.
We typically versus untuned see like a
factor of maybe threeish. It really
depends on your problem.
But at this point, I'll say that it's
enough of a difference that we consider
we consider like a full hyperparameter
sweep to be uh a required part of
research,
solving all games on the puffer cluster
headless in 2028. I mean, this is
basically what we're doing right now,
right? Like, I'm literally just having
this thing. It's not doing anything
complicated, right? It's just basically
doing what I would do if I were to like
run train on each end on a different
GPU, build, fix any obvious screw-ups
with the thing crashing or whatever, log
whatever is wrong, and then kick me back
any errors so I can address any errors
here.
Larger versus stacking,
small size, but multiple layers.
Um, I don't think there's a massive
massive difference, Jess. Like,
they probably scale together roughly.
If you want a default like 3x128
or 3x 256 is probably fine. Like I
probably more layers at higher dim. I
don't know.
Um, I think wider is good up to a point
though because the extra maple calls are
linearly slower where the increased
hidden size is not linearly slower until
you get it big Enough.
And I think did we do snake on 2 or 3 0
like 110ish score?
Total agents. Yep, this is all fine.
We're happy with this.
biggest to use is reward design,
which half the times is unnecessary.
Yeah, you really don't want to go ham on
reward design, frankly.
Like the delta based rewards for
continuous stuff is kind of useful
cuz they're not hackable.
He's also has where is he now?
I don't know where he is now.
robotics. I had to do reward design.
Robotics is a mess, man. The whole thing
is this like a locally optimal jigsaw
puzzle disaster.
I'm not going to take no for an answer
on that one because I remember back when
RL was still very popular. I remember
the robotics RL people being less
competent at the RL side than the games
RL people and the games RL side people
were disaster to begin with.
Uh let me see
big mini batch sizes.
There you go.
Why using Grock? Cuz it's faster.
And uh as of today, it's apparently also
uh just as good
Yes, I've tried all the alternatives.
They're all dumb. Uh they all make
utterly laughable, stupid mistakes. The
main difference is how long that they
make me sit here waiting in between. And
if they make her sit, if they make me
just sit here waiting in between for too
long, they're like not even valuable
whatsoever versus me doing everything
fully manually.
Like what is this thing doing right now?
This is basically just saving me some
orchestration work of like having to go
manually go through each environment,
you know, run the build command, wait 10
seconds, run the launch command, right?
And it can do this in parallel for the
eight different GPUs.
So that would probably take me like I
don't know 45 minutes. And this thing
can do it in like 15 minutes or 10
minutes. It's actually like has
experiments running as well at the same
time here.
Um but if it's going to sit there and
take two hours to write the code harness
to set that basic stuff up, then it's it
goes to zero value because now it's just
wasting my time.
We definitely need to improve the way
that we uh we set up our demos.
Oh, I've tried to use the agents for
stuff more complex. They like they fail
horrendously and then they waste even
more of my time.
Even some most of the time, even when I
think I'm trying to do something that's
fairly simple, they still fail and waste
my time.
I had an agent just like revert a chunk
of code that was the the core control
condition for my experiments yesterday
without me noticing and wasted the next
3 hours worth of my own work like trying
to figure out what was on.
Yeah. I I don't know how I can tell you
guys other than like that [ __ ] does not
work.
It's like if I get one idiot to do it
and another idiot to check it, it's
still going to be wrong.
Like you're basically just deluding
yourself if you think that you can like
prompt the stupid language models into
not being Stupid
again. adding a tell like 10. You can't
prompt your language model into not
being stupid.
I'm trying to think how I want to
organize this to like chuck it on the
website.
Yeah, glitzy. I'm I'm trying to think
what we should do with the like the
website with our baselines.
I mean we do like have constellation for
this right
I think constellation's already the
right thing and we just have to like
locally
basically check all the scores.
We check over the sweeps.
Uh, did you see the massive multiGPU
sweep bug that Finn reported this
morning?
I actually can look at those sweeps now
from you, though.
Let me go look. I'm going to use the
restroom real quick and then I'll take a
look at your sweeps. Be right back.
any multiGPU thing. Okay, if you haven't
done multiGPU sweeps, then you're fine.
Let me see what you've sent over.
uh, what am I looking at? Glitzy, do you
have more screenies than this?
We got drive
which is I think this is a restricted
bit like I don't know if it's the full
length but it's fine.
Yeah, I'll look at any individual
curves. That's nice.
Basically, anything that looks weird is
something that I can possibly go fix on
the end side or whatever right now.
only drone went kind of boom. We'll
double check that.
Okay. Yeah.
Oh no, this is I think this is not even
merged in correctly is why.
So, we'll we'll do freeway and then
we'll get drone.
I honestly wouldn't be surprised if we
just get a solo
Let's say this. Let's see.
Oh, this is going to be useful. Thank
you, actually.
Something screw with asteroids if it
doesn't learn well. Uh, I believe this
curve because I think that this is
matching what I'm seeing. So, okay,
we'll figure this one out. Why does
asteroids not learn? This should be a
simple game.
So, I think we do have better results
than this, but it took a while if I
recall.
Yeah, breakout's wrong.
Look at this. 30 seconds to solve
breakout. No way.
So, I don't know what happened here.
This is really screwy. Oh, unless you're
on a really slow GPU,
but breakout taking 30 seconds is nuts.
Connect four. Oh, no. Because connect
four solves in 30 seconds. So, yeah,
that doesn't make sense. That one. Okay.
Wait, because this is breakout. Wait,
this is breakout.
Okay. And then this is connect four.
Okay. Yeah.
Drive
drone. That's [ __ ] We'll figure this
out.
Yeah. Enduro it does. Enduro does this
because um enduro is like it's an
endless thing. So it's mostly just a
function of how long you run it for.
2048 is the hard one. Uh, this one you
need to run for a long time. And this is
our most important eval task as well.
Pong is very slow,
but yes, solves.
Snake is
actually interesting that you managed to
get perf out of Snake.
Um, I might I might want some hypers
from you on Snake for this.
and Tetris. I don't know how this maps
to score, but this is the curve shape I
remember. Cool.
without changing each end.
Yeah, but like wide distributions, the
algo is supposed to narrow it.
Like the algo is supposed to narrow it,
right? Unless you're saying that you
used like a fixed model size or
something.
Let's see. Uh
oh. Yeah. Why the hell is Checker's 21k
SPS, Jess? Like, we can't use an end of
it. That's slow.
I did nothing.
That's all glitzy. Okay, that's glitzy
then. Cool.
just kind of going through and fixing
little things as I can. Right.
I kind of like look at this as just we
have a whole bunch of M's that are
running baselines and I'm just kind of
getting a stream of issues back from
this thing that I can fix.
top right point Tetris config
41K. I think we've gotten like 70k
before or something, but it's very much
just a function of compute.
Uh, what's the snake config, man? What
What was the score you got off of snake?
If you just sort this in score instead
of PF
125 in constellation. Okay, that's
actually a very useful data point. Thank
you. Can you um
How fast was that? Actually,
I'd like the hypers for um can you just
grab me the file for that snake run?
Thanks.
I'm just giving this thing like a
constant stream of random little things
and like fixing things as I can.
What do you guys think of um I one of
the things I want to do in 5 is like cut
down the clone time. Um I'm going to
have to figure out how to do that very
carefully. Um but like one obvious thing
is we're shipping a ton of model files.
Those could live in the website
repository instead.
or elsewhere. There.
That was a That's a helpful thing. Let's
see. See this the sweeps help.
sweeps up.
Uh yeah, the breakout definitely
shouldn't take that long. We literally
have breakout down to a second is pretty
optimistic. Like 1 second breakout is
optimistic. Um you kind of need to have
a good seed for that, but you can
definitely get stable solves within 1.5.
Well, we have mazes full solved at 47.
That's amazing.
Amazing.
be pretty happy to drop the whole pryio
sampling path.
It' be really nice. You know, bio
sampling is a little bit of an
annoyance.
Okay, it looks like this is um
real neural MMO bug.
Kind of embarrassing.
Yep.
Very embarrassing.
Lambda was really weird on this. Is this
gamma? This gamma.
Did I get 9.4 out of this? I don't
remember having 9.4. for a deal.
Oh,
not really. My game similarly complex
maybe.
Okay,
pilot is up.
you want me to send a PR for a robot
arm?
Ask you'd like to see.
I mean, I've been at this point, man,
I'm ready to see any PR from you because
I always see you doing all sorts of
random stuff and we haven't gotten any
NPRs out of you. So, if you have a cool
robot hand,
I will review a PR quite happily.
Only thing I ask is that it be
reasonably cleaned up to the point that
I don't just like find like I don't open
the file and have the first 100 lines of
it be defensive agent slop uh defensive
checks.
microscopy. That'd be nice.
I mean, I have always said that a robot
arm is uh like that is one of the items
I've wanted to do for like cuz I I don't
really have a huge interest in
humanoids. Um but like industrial arms,
that's a totally different story. Those
are broadly very very very useful.
They're still kind of clunky
in a way,
Yeah, I'll merge that glitzy for sure.
Particularly if we have community
interest in like doing stuff around it.
I'm not super picky with NPRs either.
I'm way more picky with core PRs.
Jess, not sure if I caught what
thoughts.
Um,
I mean, in general, Jess, I still
consider
I still consider chess to be a really
good scaling task for selfplay.
I think it's pretty likely that the
reason that we're not pushing chess
further at the moment
is due to deficiency in selfplay.
I think as a whole selfplay is not a
solved problem.
Um I don't think are there any direct
analog comparisons on chess with
selfplay? I don't think there are.
Right.
If there are and it's just like yeah
they use a way bigger model I think it
is worth trying that for sure
just to see
because even if that is the case we can
probably ablade it back down.
Um, and if nothing like that works, then
it is probably just on the selfplay
algo, like the core algo
non search. Okay, cool. there are no
good analoges in terms of nonarch
I'd probably still want to take your
configs and like just see if it's if
like the performance with selfplay is
obviously just scaling super hard on end
size on uh model size like if we just
crank model if the selfplay just
skyrockets up then okay we have to scale
the model size right but if not if that
doesn't work and it doesn't seem like
there are any real levers of
improvement, then I'm going to suspect
it's a data diversity problem, which is
fundamentally a core selfplay issue.
cranking model up big time. So I'll have
to ask him the sensitivity.
It is possible to create tasks that just
require big model. Um
that is definitely possible.
Can you go look at the like can you post
me or whatever the architecture used by
um whatever that like tiny distilled
chess model was that was done recently
or the go model. It might have been a go
model but same thing in my mind.
one. Okay.
It still should be way faster.
That's still pretty big discrepancy.
See?
Illegal
moves.
still not sure what we're going to do
with the the final models. here.
Oh yeah. Yeah. So um biasing speed like
biasing wall clock speed will give you
totally different hypers and that is
correct. That is like the design of the
algo.
Uh, okay.
I see. Reset handling mess,
I guess. Is there anything else I'm
forgetting guys for like um actual
release of 5
that I said that I would do? Cuz
obviously we got to get all the end
baselines. I have final algorithm
changes in development that obviously we
will test on the major benchmarks. I
don't know whether or not they will
improve uh anything by a large amount,
but they should simplify some things and
make a little bit faster.
addressing we have addressed selfplay
Jess that is already in uh we have
already made massive improvements to
selfplay and this is what Spencer is
actively working on and I'm going to be
chatting with him as well uh this week
on That
So, I did a whole bunch of work porting
and cleaning up specifically the
selfplay code. I have to chat with
Spencer to see if there are any
algorithmic changes he's made that would
cause us to need to make a big edit to
the core code. I don't think there is.
Um, but yes, I will that will be
addressed using at the minimum Robocode
and probably Slime Volley. Um, possibly
more.
Did they write out this architecture
anywhere?
overwrites number of CPU cores to one.
Ah, lovely.
Uh, that will dramatically bias your
results. Yes,
that will dramatically bias your
results.
That snake config that you sent me was
still very useful though,
as were some of the curves.
Yes, I remember that the model is
distilled. Just
I will confirm for you that I do
remember the model is distilled
still on search as well.
Well, yeah, but Jess, like in my mind,
this is like the easiest thing ever to
test, right? Like you literally just get
like take Grock or anything else, get it
to port the thing, like validate it bit
forbit versus the original
and train it and see if it works, right?
like um it's not something that like if
I were going to do it manually and take
a week, I wouldn't bother.
Oh, I'm skeptical, too. But it's like in
my mind it's free.
Okay, let's talk about some other stuff
in the meanwhile, right, while we do
this. Um, what are we going to do about
all these model files? So,
we have some M's with kind of chunky
assets.
Most of them are pretty small.
Some of them I could probably even have
um Grock or whatever just make a sprite
sheet for to clean them up a little bit.
Don't have to be too big
and get puffer down to like under 100
megs for sure. Um we don't really need
to ship the models
like the weight files with this
trying to bench. Uh, there was a major
bug apparently in the OBS for Neural
MMO.
So, I think it might still be worth us
doing like a big run to see with the
broken obs if we're still better or not.
Um, but we'll set we should set soda
pretty easily regardless.
Maybe it'll still be worth running it
for a trillion steps after we fix this
as well. I wouldn't be surprised. Neural
MMO is very far from solved.
It has some like net hack
um net hack level indirection on some of
the stuff that you have to Turn.
sweep ranges?
We do.
Huh?
What are you talking about?
Look at all the sweep ranges, my guy.
They're inherited.
If you don't specify the ranges, they
all get used from the defaults.
OBS. Uh, there was an OBS corruption
where like something wasn't getting
zeroed. So, it was kind of getting like
this smeared version of an observation
where like the enemies would kind of
just like smear trails behind them. It
was weird.
It's technically still learnable, but
it's very janky.
I don't really want to make another
repo.
I guess the website needs the models
anyways. So that's like a reasonable
place to stick them
Basically, all we'd have to do, in fact,
is just do that.
That's pretty easy.
me how many folks use the defaults.
Oh, because the defaults are fine, Jess.
You should not need to change those very
much per task. Like the default ranges
on sweeps are fine.
Mhm.
Interesting.
Almost always
lower the learning rate. Really? Our
learning rate range is already really
low, man.
Oh, lower the range.
Um, that's possibly just a bad global
default in that case, honestly, just
because
catch something without realizing it.
Um,
it's fine.
We need to change the learning rate
analing [ __ ]
and snake as well. Right, we have a
couple things left to figure out.
I do think we're going to want to move
all the stuff over. Oh, you know what we
can do for the next hour while this [ __ ]
runs?
I was going to say net hack, but let's
not be that that lazy. Okay.
I'm very attached to our current one,
though.
Send there.
This here is a puffer fish. He is our
mascot.
And ideally, we're going to make it very
easy to use him as the uh the character
in a bunch of environments.
So, every time I have a little bit of
time where I don't know what to do, I
kind of just work on this a little bit.
Nope.
See? F1. F1. F1.
Little better. Right.
Oh, I see the problem.
Okay.
Oh yeah. Very very small differences in
the eyes make a huge difference.
A bit in the flat in the face. Yeah.
Yeah, it is. So, the thing is I can't
tell.
Is it flat in the face? I actually think
it's too round in the face if you look
on
The way that the spikes are done is
definitely janky.
eyes are very very slightly
uneven. I think
Oh no, it's the [ __ ] swim. They're
not fixed correctly, are they?
Honestly, I don't I I'm out of energy to
deal with this properly today.
I think we're just going to leave this
going.
And uh we're going to chill for a little
bit while this runs. Try the net hack
thing out again. See if I can understand
what our agent is doing a little bit
better and then call it. I'll be right
back.
earlier breakout plot and the Discord
way better.
Yeah, that's more reasonable.
quick net hack break
before dinner.
And this is specifically to try to
figure out um if we can play like the
agent.
Yeah, we're on level three. Cool.
This is no mish mines.
We're basically just seeing whether
the agent's dumb strat
gets you pretty far.
I'm very tempted to start dipping long
sword at level five.
Oops.
Teleport trap.
Um, I mean, we have lots of different
baselines we're working on at the moment
to run.
Okay, cool.
Fun trap.
Where the heck is this entrance?
Am I dumb?
I mean, it does still you have to learn
exploration.
Even if you're rushing levels, you have
to learn efficient exploration
because sometimes
the the entrance is just going to be
really far away and if you just kind of
meander around, you'll run out of food
or like something bad will happen,
right?
Okay, there's our entrance.
We can explore a little bit.
but not too much. Teleport trap. Lovely.
Oh, lovely.
That's what happens when you go too
fast.
First load stone.
Maybe don't pick those up. Jesus, man.
No wonder.
We didn't really get to test much of
anything there, did we?
I do kind of wonder
just by having AC zero.
still takes a while to even test.
Whoops.
Oh, statues. Let's just not do that.
really want to get the uh that hack
setup going well.
really have anything good to open it
with
bow. Interesting. I think we could learn
to keep our our pony with us.
I think that's a reasonable thing that
we could learn, right?
So, actually, what do we even need?
We need boots to get us to like minus
two.
And we could wear uh like a robe, maybe,
right?
and get minus. How am I AC3?
Wait, wait, wait. I started AC0. What
the heck?
I'm confused.
Didn't I Am I crazy or did I start AC0?
Why am I now AC3?
Wait, that's crap.
Did I lose
I'm confused. Did I lose something?
Actually, I'm going to rewind the
stream.
Hello.
Okay, there we are.
That was dying in Nomish mines. Very
cool. Yep. Nice job.
Oh, it is AC3.
Huh. I could have sworn I started AC0.
That's nowhere near as good then
as I as I expected.
You have plus one ring mail. I guess
this the shield is just not
you don't get the Valk shield, right?
I don't really think this is going to be
a
Oh, I'm dead.
Floating eye. Okay.
If I'm less careless
Okay, I'm not going to be able to do the
strat that the agent does and just
speedrun it because like there's too
much micro that you just screw up.
What?
Yeah, that's a mute. Jesus.
Um,
wait. Hang on.
This is the wrong one.
Mhm.
Okay, that's tough.
Should be good. Anyone
else?
And confirm
I just wanted to do that real quick
because um
I wanted to try a couple things on that
hack that I've been thinking of.
It is somewhat annoying to not be able
to test
the strap that the agent uses
efficiently.
I think if anything I'm more impressed
now that it gets well average depth 10
with a long tail.
We move all the models out.
Redo sweeps. We still have this thing to
deal with.
So, this version of the code basically
just needs to sweep 2048 now, I'd say.
We can actually do that here.
Yeah, this is not effect this is not
effective at all. Um
I'm just being kind of dumb at the
moment.
This needs to get swept.
I really, really don't want to have to
pack all this stuff up.
Another thing I can do is I can fix the
architecture, right?
That should help.
One second.
Hey, Kvert.
Uh, I mean, we have lots of things fixed
up already now,
but the main thing is the getting the
algo changes merged in and making sure I
didn't break anything in the process of
doing that. That's what we're going to
figure out now.
I swear if it's
if this is some [ __ ] again,
if this is the same guy that's been
making AIPRs for the last week.
Oh no, it's not. This is glitzy. Good.
This is glitzy. Good.
I actually I killed this intentionally
glitzy because you never use protein
other than
uh other than for the entire program,
right?
This is fine.
Nice.
Let me get everything stable and then
I'll merge lots of stuff.
Just lean it out. Okay.
Yeah, I actually I I thought about that
for a while, but then I was like, why do
we have all these lines of just freeze
when this is never ever going to be used
outside of the whole program?
Yeah, if you want to split it and push
again, that'd be that saves me a few
minutes. Thank you.
one commit with everything. I do not
care how you structure your commits.
If you autocommit on every keystroke,
hang on, one exception. If you like auto
commit on every keystroke or every save
and have like a thousand commits or some
[ __ ] then I'm going to get a little
bit annoyed. But as long as you're not
like whoever that guy is that does that,
it's like on like the most p like most
commits ever, whatever. Like as long as
you don't do that, I don't care. That's
the exception.
Anybody else commit to that? I forget if
anybody else did that.
on the website, but it is in get. It is
in get.
Where the heck is it?
Huh?
It's supposed to be in here somewhere.
Uh, I don't know where that went. Did I
call it something else?
Well, I'm sure that source is somewhere.
Um, we can find that and grab it if
anybody wants to finish it. It's
supposed to be on Git, so it's probably
somewhere in the tree. You can probably
just search it. It was I think it was
just TCG originally.
Um it's not intentionally closed source
or anything. We say right on the website
that we don't have like we don't do
that. Our stuff's all open.
Okay, the GPUs are all idle.
Actually,
look how quickly we can commit this
stuff up.
Yeah, if you found it in Git History and
you'd like to help us clean that up, by
all means. Um, I think that one was
vaguely based off of Magic the Gathering
to begin with. It could pretty easily be
a generic TCG sim.
I think the code for that was actually
pretty decent as well. I wrote like
that's one of the M's that I wrote
personally or at least a I don't think I
wrote the c the latest version of it
personally but I wrote a version of it
wondering whether Puffer likes doing
search.
No, we do just like mostly on Paul um
fast sim like no search. We actually
have a big project on chess, trying to
do chess without search.
Search is cool where it's applicable. I
don't see any general way to like do
search everywhere though. Um, and like a
lot of the problems I care about in
particular, search doesn't make a ton of
sense to me.
You can kind of do something similarish
with state sets, but it wouldn't be like
MCTS.
Uh,
so
yeah, I'm not super big on search
generally.
Also, I haven't ever seen a version of
it that's like reasonably fast.
You kind of light compute on fire quite
quickly.
Thanks, Glitzy. I really got to go in a
second. I'm just launching the sweep.
Um, but I will check that after.
I do have a number a fair number of
people watching. Hang on, let me log
this in. Just check.
up in it. Yeah. I will give a a quick
summary
um of what I've been working on today
and then I will uh I'll call it. So
essentially, right, we have all these
ends
that are on the 40 version of the code.
They had to get ported up to 50. They're
just a ton of miscellaneous stupid
little quirks with different things
going wrong. So I kind of just got an
8GPU box and uh like had Grock go
through all the different M's and fix
very small things and like you know
report errors back and I just handled a
lot of different errors myself with
that.
Um, we merged in a few critical fixes.
We, uh, fixed a bunch of ends that were
having bad results that had regressions.
On the side here, we also have, uh, some
new algo tests with a sweep running
here. And there will be a sweep running
over here in a second as well.
I don't know what this is doing, but
whatever. This is a one-off. Um,
so h ideally we're going to be able to
get the final algorithm changes tested
in by tomorrow and then I'll be able to
merge the algo changes with a bunch of
simplifications. I'll be able to clean
up the code quite a lot and then after
that I will be able to merge in all the
end fixes
and we will be able to clean up 50
release and at least have a stable
pre-release the end of this weekend.
Awkwards
anti-cancer software. Thank you. State
sets is uh we were going to do this in
5, but we ended up switching our goals
for 50 and 6o. So state sets is actually
going to be 6o
So when you say 250k SPS, like is that
250k searches or is it like 250k x
something?
This doesn't make any bloody sense to
me.
search is depth dependent
250k neural net evals.
Wait, 1024 times 250k positions eval.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
That's
Wait, that doesn't make sense.
Two, you can't do 250k batches of 1024
per second.
That's 250 million through the network
per second. That's not possible.
How is each neural net eval doing 100
doing 1024 positions
batch size? Yeah, but you can't be doing
250k calls over batch size 10 like 1024
per second. That's not possible.
Wait, 250 2.5 mil.
Uh, yeah. No, you can't have because it
to be 250 million obviously, right? Uh,
250 million items through per second is
not possible.
Inflated. Yeah,
that's not possible.
That would be like double or triple the
PF of puffer on our like stupid fast GPU
ends with a trivially small network.
I the GPUs doesn't go that fast.
Okay, I have to go. I can't figure this
out right now. Groc is [ __ ] Um,
there's your evaluation of the new
model. It's This is a completely stupid
fix. It's like, yeah, it's fine all day.
And then it does some like 12year-old
level idiocy. So, whatever. Um, thank
you everyone. Please uh start the puffer
on GitHub. It's all open source. I'll be
back probably tomorrow, maybe uh
tomorrow or Friday, streaming more of
this.